operations have been suspended at
Ukraine's Ismail port on the Danube
after a Russian drone strike they bring
Romania's President says Russian attacks
on Ukraine's Port facilities along the
Danube River are unacceptable Russian
forces carried out drone attacks in
Odessa on Tuesday night Office Buildings
as well as grain silos and warehouses
were damaged the area is a vital route
for Kiev to export grain at a time when
many other routes been closed off
the Kremlin intensified attacks in the
Odessa region after withdrawing from the
U.N brokered grain deal last month that
allowed ships carrying Ukrainian grains
safe Passage through the Black Sea grain
can also be transported over land by
truck or train but the rail option
through Poland and other EU members is
hampered by various countries using a
different track size from Ukraine
another route is through the congested
black seaport of Constanta in Romania
that's time consuming and costly so is
shipping on the Danube River and its
network of canals
in a moment we'll go live to Julia
chapovalova in Moscow but first let's go
to cinema console
actually let's go first instead to Yulia
chapovalova in Moscow we'll go to cinema
in a bit so Julio first of all what are
Russian officials saying about the
suggestions coming from Turkey of the
possibility of in Return of Russia to a
new grain deal
yes of course we can discuss the
telephone talks between the two
presidents between President Putin and
president erdogan and indeed the
president discussed the possible
resumption of the grain deal which
allows for the safe export of Ukrainian
grain from its Black Sea ports Mr Putin
said that Russia as a reliable partner
was ready to supplies grain free of
charge in countries to countries in need
he confirmed his Readiness to return to
it as soon as the West fulfills its
obligations towards Russia and Russia's
conditions are met and here's what his
press secretary Dimitri peskov had to
say about that
foreign
and there's been quite a bit of Russian
targeting of Ukrainian ports do they
think that this strategy is working
well actually by targeting a Ukrainian
seaport Russia shows it's been serious
about keeping its promise out of the
grain deal withdrawal to consider All
Ships on their way to and from Ukrainian
ports potential carriers of military
cargo on the one hand Russia targets the
port infrastructure in and around Odessa
saying it destroys foreign military hard
work coming from abroad for the
Ukrainian Army while the Ukrainian side
says Russia wants to strangle Ukraine
not only militarily but also
economically by not allowing it to
export its green something that was
bringing Ukraine tens of billions of
dollars in profit in the past in general
a business part of Russia's Global
strategy aimed at destroying Ukraine's
infrastructure it's all part of a plan
to force Ukraine to surrender
thanks very much to Yulia there let's
continue this now though with Cinema she
joins us from Istanbul and there was
some talk about
from from Turkish officials about a
return to a new grain deal what can you
tell us about that synonym
president's office today said that
presidents are done during his phone
call with his Russian counterpart
emphasized the importance of moscow's
return to the grain deal and yes Moscow
has been
sending green signals however it is not
clear whether there is really a hope or
not because this attack in Odessa region
to the Ismail poor just happened over
the night and the phone talk between two
presidents was already planned because
we heard from Kremlin that this phone
talk was already going to happen on
Wednesday so uh of course both sides
know how to speak to each other both
leaders know how to do diplomacy
together or can leave aside the
different differences when there is a
mutual interest to work on but of course
it apparently there is some time for
this return to the grain deal but this
is what true Kia hopes because for
turkey it is not only a diplomatic win
for president erdon but also the safety
of Black Sea is very important as long
as this a black sheep grain deal
initiative continues as president Ardon
considers this grain deal as a Peace
Bridge everything will be fine for
turkey but it seems President Putin also
wants to keep the door open for his
commitments to the African countries
because last week we saw that in Saint
Petersburg Russia Africa Summit was held
and Russian president pledged that he
would be sending grains to the African
countries yes there is a hope for the
extension of the grain deal when and how
is the land clear Sammy and that's in
console reporting from Istanbul
Ukraine urgently needs more medical
supplies as intensified fighting on the
front lines results in more soldiers
being wounded Medics who depend on
donations say they regularly receive
supplies that are unusable sometimes
donations are stolen Steve Austin
reports from kharkiv
combat medic Danish midov shows us a
Macabre collection he calls the Museum
of tourniquets that kill tourniquets
donated to Frontline Maddox in Ukraine
to make a difference between life and
death unfortunately these tourniquets
are useless they cannot stop the
critical bleeding they will not work
they will not save their life some of
them are married in USA some of them
this one was made in Israel
like I've taken it on the front line
from the Israeli volunteer I've taken it
say like I said give this one to me and
I will give you normal one Jan check
Markov just returned from the front line
where he says soldiers urgently need
equipment to operate blood and
evacuation vehicles
very necessary because there are a lot
of soldiers coming to our stabilization
point the Russians are storming our
position and they are very good at using
drones
foreign
for a group called Ukrainian Fighters is
suing first aid kits sent from Poland
before soldiers can use them not all
medical donations are reaching the front
lines the authorities are currently
investigating The Disappearance of first
aid kits worth one million dollars sent
by the us since the start of the war
several officials including the deputy
defense minister have lost their jobs
after corruption involving support for
the military was uncovered
president zelenski recently said he had
no more tolerance for officials who
would jeopardize Ukraine's
anti-corruption Drive needed for EU
admission aware of the risks relief
centers like this one register all
donations
I think that corruption is very bad and
corruption with medical supplies is the
worst thing that can happen moreover
this is the moment when human life is
very very valuable
with fighting intensifying human lives
are increasingly at stake combat Medics
urge the government not only demand more
weapons but focus on medical supplies
too if we will not provide the best
medical help to our Warriors we will
lose this war because uh if all our
wounded soldiers will die who will be
who will be fighting to save lives
well-functioning tourniquets are badly
needed like the ones Danish midov shows
us step fast and Al Jazeera hakif
Ukraine